when you're cooking for a special
occasion you want to nail some key
things
one your recipes need to be bulletproof
you don't want a disaster
on the big day two as well as tasting
phenomenal
they have to be easy to serve so you can
relax and enjoy yourself three
when you're out to impress food needs to
look great too
my first recipe fits the bill perfectly
stuffed lamb with spinach
and pine nuts stuffed meats are perfect
for special occasions they look
impressive taste amazing but more
importantly they are so
simple to do
pan on for the stuffing it's a saddle of
lamb
basically a sort of rolls-royce cut
perfectly shaped
and it suits stuffing to an absolute tea
for the stuffing finely chop an onion
garlic nice thin slices
oil in onions and garlic
in just salt
and pepper make sure the stuffing is
beautifully seasoned so it helps to
season the inside
of the lamb now we've got the color on
those onions
we're gonna throw in some pine nuts and
that helps to
give a bit of a texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting
spinach in and just lay the spinach over
the pinenuts
it looks like a lot of spinach that's
gonna condense and disappear
almost instantly
there's so much more flavor in spinach
when you saute it as opposed to
steaming it or boiling it gas off look
at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
breadcrumbs
crumpled feta over the spinach feta
cheese
adds a beautifully salty sharp and
creamy flavor
what this does it brings our stuffing
together
now open up the lamb
keep those little fillets to the side
that's the channel that we want to stuff
so i want to just open that up a little
bit there
salt and pepper lightly
and before we put our stuffing in we're
going to season it with
sour sumac is a wonderful lemony spice
that goes brilliantly with lamb and you
can get it in most big supermarkets and
it sort of cuts through that
thick rich sweetness of the lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon if you're preparing this
for the day
ahead then let the stuffing cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it
something's gonna squeeze out so load up
the ends
take these beauties these little fillets
and just support
that stuffing and sort of increase
that beautiful tunnel and then from
there
over there and bring that
towards you and then roll like i said
some of the stuff is going to come out
now to tie it
first off around the side and don't
worry about some flash
butcher's knot just tie it
one in the middle you can get butcher
string from your local butcher
or at cookware shops i got two ties
go too thai it just forces all that
stuffing
out of the lamb when it's in the oven
nice
now we just season the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but
get your tray onto the gas oil in
get it really nicely colored none of
your stuffing is coming out of the sides
really important look at that color
beautiful
does kickstart the roasting process
gas off into the oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink
you want your lamb
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin will
stop it cooking
but not cool it down too quickly and
means you won't lose any of those lovely
juices
next i'm making a simple but
sophisticated accompaniment for the lamb
top and tell the cucumber peel it
cut the cucumber into three
and just core taking out all that it's
just sort of watery seedy and
it spoils the flavor slice the cucumber
cucumber in really nice way of making a
cheap and cheerful cucumber look
glamorous we're gonna dress that
cucumber
with a nice fresh yogurt a couple of
tablespoons
next some fresh mint dressing
a touch of salt a touch of pepper
and then pomegranate molasses that just
sweetens it up
finish that with lemon
mix that up
lamb it's rested carefully take off the
string
and then just gently pull them back
straightened edge knife that's going to
cut through that
crispy fat on the outside instantly i
tied it purposely so i can get
my portion control from the lines hold
it nice and firmly
look at your line where the string was
and look
this one is going to be amazing lay
and down just in those two slices there
it proves that stuffing meats
is for special occasions because that is
a saddle of lamb at its absolute
best stuffing meats and fish
not only makes them look fantastic it
also gives them an extra added flavor
dimension too
once you've mastered the technique
you'll be able to turn out dishes that
will guarantee
you'll have an unforgettable feast here
are three more of my favorite easy stuff
dishes that are perfect for any feast
first up chicken with garlic and
chestnut stuffing packed with flavor
and earthy richness
for the stuffing fry finely chopped
onion garlic
and celery in hot olive oil
next add pine nuts which have a lovely
creamy taste
and chopped earthy cooked chestnuts
both add a wonderfully chewy texture and
richness to stuffings
season
and add chopped parsley
[Music]
then stir in cooked wild rice
next take a whole debone chicken it's
fitting to do at home
but if you ask your butcher will do it
for you and pile the stuffing mixture
along the center now simply roll the
chicken up tightly
and tie it with your butcher string
then roast in a hot oven for just over
an hour
[Music]
simply carve into magnificent thick
slices
so impressive so easy and trust me this
is a dish guaranteed
to get a fantastic reaction on any
occasion
whole stuffed fish will always make an
impression my next recipe is
sea bass stuffed with fennel lemon and
capers
first place a whole gutted sea bass on
foil and season the fish
inside and out sea bass is known as the
king of the seas and has a wonderful
sweet white flesh
start the stuffing with sliced fennel
its aniseed flavour works brilliantly
with the fish
next add capers fresh dill
and slices of lemon then dot in knobs of
butter
lastly add a splash of white wine which
helps to steam the fish
and creates a lovely sauce and seal
tightly into a parcel
this locks in all the juices and flavor
then simply bake in a medium oven
unwrap and hear your guess ooh and ah
with delight
prepared in 10 minutes wrap for intense
flavor a stunning sea bass that's bound
to create a stir
[Music]
my next dish throws a spanish twist on a
classic english roast
pork stuffed with manchego and mandrillo
use a pork loin roasting joint
lay the joint skin side down and cut
three quarters of the way into the flesh
creating space for the stuffing
next thinly sliced spanish manchego
cheese this has a wonderful buttery
nutty taste
and is fantastic for stuffing as it
melts brilliantly
sliced spanish mimbrello quince jelly
sweet and perfumed
is the perfect partner for the saltiness
of the cheese
then simply layer your cheese and quince
jelly into the pork
add sage leaves for a strong and
deliciously bitter flavour
roll the meat up
and tie with butcher string
next add more sage leaves and some
aromatic fresh thyme
to a roasting tin then lay the pork on
top
skin side up cut a bob of garlic in half
and wedge it under the meat the garlic
wedges help lit the pork
so it roasts to perfection and will add
a sweet depth of flavor
to your gravy drizzle with olive oil
season and roast for just over an hour
with the heat on high for the first 20
which helps get the skin crispy and
golden
once cooked leave the pork to rest as
you make a stunning gravy
simply place the roasting tin over a
medium heat
add a lug of sherry and delays using the
roasting juices gives your gravy
maximum flavor simmer
and reduce for a few minutes then pour
in the incredible resting juices from
the pork
finally strain the silky rich gravy over
the stuffed loin
and serve immediately stuff through with
incredible flavor
rich sweet and aromatic a stunning
centerpiece
fit to grace any table anywhere anytime
three dishes stuffed to perfection proof
you can have food that's simple to pull
off but looks incredible and tastes a
million bucks
amazing